la consigne est claire il faut tourner
la page de cette séquence un message
martelé désir par les ministres lors du
Conseil national du parti Renaissance et
donc c'est vraiment une victoire
collective c'est un travail collectif et
c'est aussi notre capacité à montrer que
même dans la difficulté nous savons
réformé je crois qu'il faut garder cet
épisode comme un encouragement dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent autour
du président de la République
c'est vrai
agir c'est aussi faire des réformes les
faire peut-être différemment avec une
méthode différente plus consultée plus
organiser les choses avec le Parlement
et les partenaires sociaux
personne ne veut refaire la retraite
bise Emmanuel Macron vient de promulguer
en une nuit il avait dit alors qu'il a
15 jours qu'il ferait en 48 heures et
finalement il le fait à la sauvette la
première nuit c'est un braquage
démocratique est-ce qu'il fallait la
fait parce qu'il fallait agir vite ou
est-ce que vous estimez comme d'autres
qu'il a fait par provocation il l'a fait
dans la logique qui est la sienne depuis
le départ
ça veut dire aller vite pour réformer
absolument
sans tenir compte de l'impact que ça le
problème que nous traversons aujourd'hui
c'est une crise de régime c'est que
d'une certaine manière le 14 avril est
morte la Cinquième République il aurait
très bien pu attendre demain soir pour
dire cher compatriotes j'ai décidé de
promulguer il l'a fait aussi tôt il y a
pas lieu de son étonner c'est dans la
droite ligne de ce qui s'est passé
encore une fois depuis ce fameux Jeudi
Noir comment voulez-vous passer à autre
chose quand vous avez fait vous avez
fait coup de force sur coup de force
vis-à-vis de l'Assemblée vis-à-vis des
syndicats vis-à-vis du peuple c'est une
chose insupportable on prend un plaisir
étonnant à jeter les Français les uns
contre les autres à brutaliser le peuple
français en réalité à gouverner contre
le peuple français il s'en fait presque
une gloire j'étais très choquée
d'entendre le président de la République
dire ne rien lâcher c'est ma devise la
devise de la République c'est liberté
égalité fraternité et ce serait bien
qu'il s'en souvienne il y a trois
solutions pour sortir d'un conflit tel
que celui qu'il a lui-même engendré il y
a le référendum qui est un bon moyen qui
est prévu par la Constitution il y a la
dissolution de l'Assemblée nationale et
il y a la démission du président de la
République
nous dit qu'il a compris ça fait 25 fois
qu'il nous dit qu'il a compris et
derrière il n'y a jamais le moindre
changement il ne peut pas je croise en
extraire et il ne peut pas venir demain
en disant on va penser à autre chose on
va réfléchir à d'autres réformes ça ne
fonctionnera pas ça ne fonctionnera plus
et c'est vous qui voulez tourner la page
moi je souhaite avancer et passer à
d'autres sujets
mais vous aimez lire quand vous tournez
une page vous n'avez pas oublié la page
précédente moi non plus le feu
[Applaudissements]
avant les déflagrations
hospitalisation et hier en région
parisienne de Jean-Marie Le Pen après un
malaise cardiaque mon père va
glorieusement sur ces 95 ans et donc ça
nécessite de temps en temps
quelques passages à l'hôpital pour faire
des réglages en quelque sorte mais il va
bien pas moins de 160 pompiers sont
déployés et des par ce robot il ne
maîtrise l'incendie que tard dans la
nuit et défenseurs du droit des animaux
qui prennent d'assaut l'hippodrome
daenri près de Liverpool objectif
retarder le coup d'envoi du Grand
National l'une des courses hippiques les
plus populaires du pays mais aussi l'une
des plus dangereuses pour les chevaux
avec 40 partants et 30 obstacles
répartis sur près de 7 km le conducteur
un des participants à cette course
sauvage a perdu le contrôle de son
véhicule et il a foncé dans la foule
bilan cette personne blessée dont un
mineur de 17 ans après 14 minutes de
retard la course a malgré tout pu avoir
lieu 118 personnes ont été arrêtées
après avoir pris la fuite le Bordelais
de 32 ans et ses trois passagers ont été
interpellés quelques kilomètres plus
loin puis placés en garde à vue une
enquête a été ouverte pour blessures
involontaires aggravées et délits de
fuite le Grand National est l'un des
rendez-vous hippique les plus commentés
du Royaume-Uni cette année trois chevaux
ont péri durant les trois jours du
tournoi